Now that our application logic and our resources are stored
in the app cache, let's talk about how we store
data locally. There are several different ways to store data
locally, many of which have developed over time. So let's
cover each of these briefly. Local storage is the oldest
and most basic of the storage APIs. It let's you
get and set key value pairs and iterate through all
the keys. However, each value is just a string and
each domain can only store a total between two
and five megabytes in local storage, depending on the browser.
There's no real searching capability. You can index through all
the keys one at a time, or you can ask
for the value associated with a particular key, but
that's basically it. The local storage API is really simple
to use, take a look at how you can store
an item using setItem, retrieve the value for a particular
item with getItem. You can remove one
key value pair with removeItem, iterate through all
the key values pairs with length key and
getIitem or clear the entire local storage system.